just been confirmed that the Royal
College of Nursing has rejected a new
NHS payoffer its members in England will
now stage further strike action that
news comes shortly after we heard from
the Unison Union about its members
including ambulance Crews and some
nurses accepting a new payoffer well
let's speak to our health correspondent
Ashish Joshi now hello to you Ashley so
we've heard two bits of news today
Unison accepting an offer the Royal
College of nurses rejecting one what
does it all mean
what it means is there's a division
between two of the biggest Health unions
and it just means more confusion more
uncertainty for those thousands of
patients who have had delays to their
appointments their procedures and now
the government will have
unions from the health sector one which
is voted for the pay deal that's been
offered to them for five percent and a
cash deal for last year and another one
representing the nurses in this country
the largest nursing Union in this
country the Royal College of Nursing
whose members have rejected the very
same pay deal that means that these
unions including unite and the GMB and
the specialist unions looking after
dietitians and physiotherapists who have
yet to announce their ballot results
don't know where they stand in the weeks
ahead the RCN has already said today
that it has announced two more strike
dates before the end of the month let's
listen now to Pat Cullen the leader of
the RCN who's speaking a few minutes ago
on these steps behind me
well clearly our members have voted to
reject the pay offer that's been put on
the table and waste a number of our
members voted to accept uh we'll listen
now to the voice of our members and
they've rejected the payoffer and we're
back now to negotiating with government
for a better payoff for our members and
what are your strike plans no well we
have issued today a notices for strike
action for the duration of our mandate
um at the end of April beginning of May
and then we will move to re ballot our
members for further period of strike
action and leading into the next six
months
how disappointing is it to you and your
senior colleagues that you negotiated
this deal and recommended it and now
it's been rejected look we've always
said
age under
members our members have made that
decision today this offer was not enough
for our members and that is now down to
the government to listen to the voice of
Nursing and put a better offer on the
table they need to restore the nurse's
pay and they need to make a better offer
but the one thing that they must not do
is to take the current offer off the
table they need to leave that on the
table and add to it
it is an absolute mess at the moment we
have unions who want to accept the pay
deal other unions who don't want to
accept the pay deal other unions have
still to hear from their members
what will happen the government on the
28th of April will ask the unions to
come back that's what the deadline
that's been said so all of the health
unions under the agenda for change will
go back to the government and they will
have to say whether they accept or
reject the government's pay deal they
will meet the government on May the 2nd
that's four days after that deadline has
passed we understand the Unison Union
will say to the government we want you
to implement the P the pay deal on our
members our members have overwhelmingly
that's by 75 percent have overwhelmingly
accepted the pay deal offered by the
government that's what Unison will tell
the government which leaves the RCN and
its members
in another difficult position Pat Cullen
already talking about balloting its
members for more payday more strike
action because its mandate ends in the
next few weeks so it has to squeeze in
the strike action before then and then
go back to its membership to ballot for
further strike action which may well
coincide with strike action being taken
by Junior doctors as well so a great
deal of uncertainty certainly not a
position that the NHS trusts patients
the government or the union members
would have wanted